hi my name is Jason Biggs and I'll be
talking about the new molecule
functionality in version 12
my name is Jason Biggs I've been with
Wolfram research for about - a little
over two years now I came in to join the
team at alpha and develop content
related to chemistry chemistry step by
step and then I've gone from there to
develop the molecule function let's have
let's look at this let's just look at
that the outline of the talk a little
bit of a motivation talk about what
we've done with chemistry in the Wolfram
language so far then we we introduced
the molecule go over the various input
forms of different ways that you can
make a molecule go over stereochemistry
how you would input this how you would
read it out something that's been sorely
missing in ah yes you know you know
what's a good size 150 125 okay alright
so then so the Wolfram language will
finally handle stereochemistry in a very
robust way the molecule is an object
that has a lot of properties it's got
lists and counts that we can go over
let's see then we'll then we'll talk
about molecule patterns and sub
structure searching which i think is a
one of the most important parts of the
molecule package we'll talk about how
you can modify a molecule how you can
change it once you've created it how you
can embed it in 3d generating new
coordinates for a molecule from scratch
which is another one of the really cool
things about this package we'll go over
a few really cool all right I'll come up
with different adjectives a few
interesting examples look at file import
and then some some future topics the
things that you're gonna ask do we do
this and I'm gonna say no maybe next
time and then and then some of this the
experimental functions that we haven't
hammered out just yet but that you might
find if you if you dig deep into a
context we're going to enable dynamics
why not let's live dangerously okay so
in the Wolfram language since version 6
we've been interested in supporting
chemists we have
port export you can import PDB files
they describe a protein you can import a
an mo L file which will otherwise known
as a mol file so you can you can put in
the coordinates for a molecule the
number of atoms like if we just took
that guy and said text you can see what
it wants living in the file yes why not
there we go so this is what lives inside
of a mol file and then now starting in
version 12 when you do that you will get
yes a molecule so but the old behavior
was when you would import a mol file you
would get a text an image either a
graphics or a graphics 3d and so we're
moving beyond that let's see also since
version 6 we've had chemical data which
is a part of the Wolfram knowledge base
where we have we collect information on
entities propane there's a there's an
entry in our database and for propane
that has lots of experimental properties
like combustion heat the van der Waals
constants all of these things for about
between forty and fifty thousand
chemicals and so that's great
also more recent is the entity value
where you can access the the Wolfram
knowledge base directly using these
these little yellow blobs called
entities and has a very nice interface
with entity value you can query from
multiple properties and multiple
entities get it back in a nice data set
we also have we also recognize the fact
that our knowledge base is limited it's
going to have a lot of it's not going to
have everything in fact so we create a
service connected pubchem so you're
gonna have access to all let's say I
think around a hundred million records
are in Pupkin so you can just query
their API using the nice service connect
functionality you ask it hey what do you
know about inching equals one s over CLO
two - C 2 - 1 - 3 and it says hey I know
a lot and there it is
sorry let's see so very recently we
introduced the Wolfram data repository
where we can take datasets that are out
there and the in the public domain and
provide a nice easy way to access them
so this would be the GD b9 dataset with
over a hundred and thirty-three thousand
chemicals featuring up to nine heavy
organic atoms so carbon nitrogen Bert
and you you can download this this as an
entity store and you can access it that
way and I've created three of these this
guy has a hundred and seven thousand
this one about 20 something thousand and
then finally we've got Wolfram Alpha
where you can where I joined the picture
you can out you can ask alpha lots of
things using a natural language how many
carbon atoms and 5.4 six kilograms of
propane it'll give the answer if you do
that on the website
it should give you a step by step and
walk you through how to how to get to
that answer so to a large extent so here
we have we have a lot of step-by-step
solutions for chemistry but when I was
creating he's like a like this one so
let's say this step by step can you tell
me what atoms inside adenosine are
aromatic so first we look at all the
items we know we grab only the ones that
are in a ring then we decide no these
guys are going to be sp3 so they can't
join it and then we walk through the
rules counting the electrons and we
decided in the end that these are the
aromatic electrons or the aromatic atoms
and when I was doing this it made use a
lot of the the graph functionality and
Mathematica but also I found that I
needed to use external tools tools that
were special built to work with a
chemical graph or any where annotations
are are Vic doing substructure searching
looking for vertices with particular
property like atomic number six or
something like that and so that's when
when I started to really look toward
having a computable
object of as they say a first-class
member of the Wolfram language so that
is what the molecule is so one thing
that people are going to wonder is
what's the difference between a molecule
and chemical data and so the main point
is that the molecule does not rely on
any curated data you could disconnect
yourself from the internet delete your
pack to delete the chemical data Pacolet
and you could still you could still
compute a wide variety of information
about about any chemical so here we make
a molecule I give it just the chemical
name benzene it's gonna parse that it
doesn't look it up in the knowledge base
it just parses it and it knows that that
that that's benzene so let's see I do
that and when you look at the input form
it's got a list of atoms a list of bonds
with their bond types and that's all we
need to know so now at this point we can
go back and say if we wanted
experimental information look at the
look at the molecule it's got a smile
string here when you take that go to
pubchem let's see
so we've already we've still defined our
pubchem so let's ask for the compound
properties and here this is M smiles so
it's asking for this molecule M asking
for its smiles I just evaluated in place
and it becomes that so now I enter and
look wonder how good the Internet is
here right so there we go so this is
what pubchem 2 is able to tell me about
this molecule and if you look here they
compute the inchi string in cheeki it's
the same that we computer because we're
using the same energy library to do so
right so that's so that's how you so
that will give you access to
experimental data on any molecule that
you might make but with a molecule it's
very easy to do to create a molecule
that nobody has ever ever heard of so
starting with us well no okay so I'm not
gonna go off-script just yet I will be
going off-script but let's go let's make
it through a little ways
right no I've got a little timer here
okay but I do think it's important that
the the molecule is robust enough that I
don't need to stick with the script last
year I presented a lot of the same stuff
but it was not so robust and if I went
off script a couple of times and we saw
some some streams of error messages but
that's not the case
today okay so we could define a list of
atoms like this this is just an oxygen
atom carbon atom here we have a nitrogen
atom with a formal positive charge so in
order to add that to annotate this n we
use the atom head and we annotate this a
oxygen with a negative charge and we
have a list of bonds where the the first
argument refers to the index the
position in the list
[Music]
okay so we evaluate the list of atoms
and bonds and we can create a molecule
from that if we want to we could
visualize it
we could even visualize it in so so when
we did that the the 2d coordinates the
structure diagram was generated on the
fly using a set of rules essentially
similar to the to the rules that a graph
uses for its graph layouts except except
here we know that when chemists look at
a molecule they like for angles to be
120 degrees they like for they like for
benzene rings to be shaped a particular
way and so using those rules we and
similarly we can generate 3d coordinates
on the fly so there we go
so if you wanted to you could omit the
hydrogen atoms from that list you could
just take the same list take any
hydrogen's out same with the bonds and
recreate the molecule they have
different expressions they're not going
to be same q1 is going to be much bigger
than the other but they are the same
chemical they're going to have the same
properties everywhere
they just because there are no
hydrogen's in the at the list of atoms
here doesn't mean that the resulting
molecule has no hydrogen's they were put
in there because because carbon likes to
have two bonds oxygen likes to have two
bonds and if we you create a molecule
with only one bond to carbon and then
we'll fill in the the remaining gaps
with hydrogen's but that's uh let's see
that is a configurable behavior you can
create a molecule from an entity so when
we look to that knowledge base we've got
propane here what we do under the hood
is we call entity value queering for all
of these different properties we get a
list and we create the molecule from
that list and so if you look at it we
actually queried them out the 2d and the
3d coordinates so if you look inside the
expression you'll see it's got both the
structure diagram coordinates and the
atom coordinates already filled in we'll
talk more about whether a molecule is
meta coordinates later let's see so you
can see that if you created the molecule
from the entity or from the just from
the string then they're equivalent right
some entities in the database do not are
not going to have all of the court all
of the information necessary like some
things can be a chemical entity but not
a molecule so polymers for instance poly
butylene late describes a class of
molecules where the there's a repeating
unit and so that's not one molecule and
so it's not going to have any of the
molecule data and so molecule is going
to tell you that it can't they can't do
it one thing that I find really exciting
is the option person so what this this
allows us to do is to parse any chemical
and almost any chemical valid chemical
name into a smile string so there's an
internal function here called name two
smiles right
and then we can take that that's that a
chemical name to methyl pent 1 een and
convert that into a smile string and
from that smile string you can make them
you can create the molecule and so this
I believe Steven might have used this
for his example in the talk so it's a
long chemical like this that gets parsed
right away so let's see what the smile
string right this happened to me a
second ago all I did was hit Apple C now
let's go back to full screen yes okay
right right so so if you wanted to look
at this smile string that that underlies
this you can do in tears and so this is
what actually is the all the information
you need to create the chemical graph
likewise for this big long monster and
created plot it all very quickly and
then finally there's the smile string
which kind of underlies all of that
we've had smile string in an import and
export for quite some time now but and
what we do there when you would do an
import string you can you can import it
as a list of rules mmm and then if you
feed that to graph and give it a
particular kind of graph layout you can
get a decent decent approximation of the
molecule I believe this is supposed to
be caffeine or some something closely
related there you could have taken that
smile that smile string now and just
feed it directly to molecule and it will
populate all of the the vertices of the
graph all the the attributes you can
just take that that smile string and go
crazy with it you can just put a big
long list of C's in here to create a
huge ring put a parenthesis here and do
the
same thing all over again and so this
this is how easy it is to go off-book
like there's most likely nobody's ever
has synthesized this particular molecule
and they want to but but you let's see
but the tools here we can we can
definitely create lots of molecules that
people would like to synthesize and have
synthesized or haven't synthesized but
would want to because they'll have a
certain set of properties I'm just
showing off the the tools here let's see
yeah so you can so there are some
examples here about mixing and matching
and jumbling up smile strings to create
weird new molecules that you try and
create 3d plots from and it's actually
very decent at generating these
structures alright so as i mentioned
before one thing that's really been
lacking in chemical data and that once
this comes out we should we should fill
in that gap in chemical data is
stereochemistry when you look when you
do let's say chemical data triphosphate
right so this this it's gonna get it's
going to give us back a 2d structure
diagram and it's not in any way going to
to tell me about the stereochemistry
about so this is a chiral center right
here meaning there are four different
ligands attached to this carbon which
come off in a tetrahedral arrangement
and the exact nature of those those
ligands be they clockwise or counter
clockwise can really have an influence
on the chemical activity so now if we
did the same thing with the molecule see
what
so what that tells me is that we have
four defined stereo centers here and
what it tells me is about the relation
yep so what it does is it tells me on
which side are these oxygens and those
hydrogen's on the five membered ring and
that can oh that can drastically
influence the overall shape of the
molecule and how it behaves inside a
cell I got one of one of the first
things I did when I came to the company
was I got of a bug report about this
particular molecule our 3d structure was
completely wrong and I said aim to me
and the user really questioned my my
chops my chemistry chops and whether I
was the man for the job but I like to
think that we're doing better now so how
do you enter the molecule right so here
is a simple example these molecule
expressions can get quite large so I'm
just going to look at a simple example
here so one with four carbons 10
hydrogen's and an oxygen let's see look
at this in 3d just for a second and you
see it's this carbon right here that is
the chiral Center he's got four
different ligands and they could be
arranged in different mental methods or
in two different configurations so the
way that we enter that is through an
option for the molecule takes a list of
associations where we tell it what type
of stereochemistry we're describing here
what the value is
first for four chiral centers what we've
chosen to do this is we describe one
atom as being the stereo center that's
the grey one that I'm pointing at we
describe one atom as the fiducial atom
the atom from which you look down and
then the ligands 3 5 & 9 let's say that
there Bam Bam Bam are going to come in
either counterclockwise or clockwise the
so this is our rather verbose way of
writing on stereochemistry you could
also just put two ant signs if you find
this method to be very readable so that
encodes the same amount of information
but just in a less human readable form
so that's encoded in the smile string so
we can make so we could take the exact
and say clockwise instead of
counterclockwise and it shows up
differently in the plot we can look at
we can ask them for their chirality the
CIP con angle angled pray log Bob to
correct me okay let's see the CIP
chirality value here is s or R and that
has to do well we could go to general
chemistry to learn what that is well no
okay so what that it what we're doing is
we're describing things in terms of
local stereochemistry the local
configuration around this atom if I
wanted to describe the global
stereochemistry the absolute
stereochemistry I would need to take a
look at step back from them from the
stereo center and apply give a rank to
every single atom in the list this would
be one two three seven nine two and then
once you've done at the configuration
around the stereo Center and ask do the
atoms appear in order of increasing
priority clockwise or counter clockwise
and that's what determines our or s so
our RS is a computed property whereas
the local stereo stereo configuration is
an intrinsic property you something you
feed when you create the molecule so we
can create those two let's see we'll
call them a counterclockwise and
clockwise we have a are not equivalent
but if we change the same test to be
enantiomers and we get a true and so
what that means is that these
to add two molecules are
non-superimposable mirror images of each
other you can look when you generate the
coordinates you can look and see that
the yellow purple and green atoms appear
in clockwise versus counterclockwise
from the two configurations so the 3d
coordinates that are generate the the
stereochemistry that you entered
likewise four double bonds so so with a
double bond let's see do I have a yeah
so here's a double bond everything
around it is going to be in a plane and
what we're talking about here are these
two chlorine atoms that are in the
double bond are they on the same side or
the opposite side so that is the
stereochemistry supports of the molecule
we can also pretend that it's a chemical
data for a little while and we can give
it properties molecule so we need to
find a molecule then we can ask for its
smile string the same way as though it
were an entity you can ask for its in
Chi and there's a whole host of computed
properties which wings will get on the
screen yep so these are are just used in
in machine learning applications so
there's going to be quite a few of right
that aren't of interest to to everybody
but like this guy right so it's a big
nice big long list of numbers that you
can use in some type of a machine
learning we'll attach it to some net
near future let's see so you can use a
molecule value if you want to get to get
multiple properties for for one Molly
you can use up so we can also query for
the properties of atoms so we want to
know the atomic number v atom this would
be this would be the syntax we use we
could also use atomic number
right we could also query for computed
properties so this is the gas tag or
partial charge so here I'm asking for
the gas tagger partial chart of 6 & 7
and they returned actually very quickly
yep
right
so Adam lists for the molecule C so we
create a molecule it's benzene
another one so even benzoate wait why
did I - ok so we make sodium benzoate
it's a nice example here because it's
got its God - Adam it's got charges on
it so we ask for the an amount of M ok
that's very interesting right so there
are 15 atoms atom atom list
alright good day you can also give atom
list a second argument that's a pattern
and with the atom list of M but only
give me those atoms whose formal charge
is not 0 the way that we construct an
atom pattern is a rule so the formal
charge is except 0 so that points me to
the oxygen and the nitrogen if I wanted
to find out where those occur in the
molecule I say make the second argument
a rule so here we go atom list mall
pattern goes to property so our pattern
is this atom object the property in this
case is going to be and ignore the fact
that I didn't learn how syntax
information works until too late that
will be fixed so that tells us that
those occur at position 9 and 10 and the
atoms list okay we can we can do we want
the formal charge greater than 0 so it's
the sodium and there's one of them if we
ask for the formal charge greater that
greater or equal than 0 it's all except
for one atom like what
here for you can search for the atomic
number you want atoms with the atomic
number great and it was with a Tomic
number greater or equal than six a bond
list and bond count worked the same way
so so you create a molecule here you can
ask for its bond list and it's
essentially going to give you the second
argument but then you can ask for only
the double bonds so there's just this
one double bond here between atoms seven
and eight mm-hmm I never know quite when
to mention this but I've made it so that
the molecule plot by default uses
tooltips to tell you where the atoms are
so I know that this is atom 7 and 8 I
found it to be really useful so you
could ask for the bond list and give the
second argument just as double you could
likewise use a pattern bond with an
underscore double and those are those
are equivalent turn the same the same
result but then what gets really fun
here is the the different kind of a
pattern you hear so here I'm gonna use a
pattern to represent a single bond a
bond between one atom that is a member
of a ring and a BA and an atom that is
not and I don't want to get any results
that have a hydrogen attached so I run
this and I get three bonds and I can
highlight those and it shows me that
indeed those are rigged atoms between
heavy yet those are bonds between heavy
atoms where one is in a ring and one is
not you can get a list of all the bonds
where both atoms are in a ring and
highlighted like this right and so this
so here I'm just showing you can apply a
style if you like or use the automatic
styling ah no so this one is kind of
neat too right so so you want to find in
a bond between an atom that has a
positive formal charge on anok and so
that's going to let's see find that
molecule
and so it's going to point out this bond
where we have a positive and a negative
atom bonded to each other all right
and so bond q why did you give a whole
slide to bond q it's a it's a very it's
a small little function but the point
being it didn't fit in the other slides
I've very often when you're doing
working on these things programmatically
you need to know if something is about
or not so you write a pattern question
mark bond acute or you know underscore
question mark bond Q something like that
and so so it's useful M is this our
atoms 1 & 2 bonded yes they are
what about atoms bond 1 & 3 they are not
and if you apply if you give it a bond
order then it better be correct or else
we will say no okay
so that brings us to molecule pattern
which may yeah may change molecule
pattern and fine molecule sub structure
so right so a molecule pattern has
basically the same structures of
molecules it's a list of atoms and a
list of bonds but the main point here is
that it doesn't need to be a full
molecule it you can have a molecule
pattern can consist of just two atoms
that have an aromatic bond between them
that will one molecule because aromatic
bonds need to be in a ring but it can be
a molecule pattern so if I wanted to
find a pattern to match a single sulfur
oxygen bond I could write that in two
different ways I could write it as a
molecule pattern with a list of atoms
and a single bond or I could just write
it like we were doing on bond list as
bond s oh and I can use fine molecule
substructure to find all occurrences of
this pattern inside a particular
molecule and in this case we see that
those are indeed true
equal if we use the smarts pattern
language then we can find a third way of
writing this is the same the same
you'll pattern which is this s tilde oh
where the tilde represents any kind of
bond but the reason we need a molecule
pattern head is because then sometime
you might want to find a sub structure
containing three more than two atoms so
here is a pattern for a sulfur with
bonded to two carbon atoms and we look
inside of em for that pattern it's there
and we can plot it and so this these are
the matches where you have a sulfur
bonded to two different carbon atoms you
could define a pattern to match any n
membered ring so this would be a ring
pattern for let's see so ring pattern
six this is the way I've defined this
here ring pattern six evaluates to have
six blanks and then bonds in between and
if you search for that inside of this
molecule that's what you find you could
define a ring pattern where six for six
atoms where one of them has to be a
nitrogen and again it comes back
throughout relatively quickly you could
take a more complicated and look for
ring patterns rings with four atoms or
rings with eight atoms and yeah so this
is what we get and then you get you
could also highlight this in 3d alright
this so I'll fly through this example
but I think it's really neat you can
define a pattern so a bond between an
atom with a positive with a negative gas
tiger partial charge and I add them with
a positive partial partial charge so
then you search inside this molecule and
you find that the sulfur here has a
pretty big positive charge and it's
drawing electrons away from me from the
neighboring oxygen and nitrogen atoms
and so this these are this is the
structure that matched that
that pattern right and then you might
want to to Ma molecule your modified no
you want to modify your molecule for the
longest time I was calling it my
modified molecule and so it's taken me a
while to give rear alkyl is not and I
know the name is confusing the molecule
is not atom Q so you can not you can
modify it in place you could take a
molecule and then just replace do a
replace all and replace the word
aromatic was single and you get a
completely different molecule so that's
so what's happening here is replacing
this phenyl group with just a cyclohexyl
group you could say I want the fifteenth
atom in that molecule to be phosphorus
instead of nitrogen and that evaluates
to be atom of P and it shows up in the
end the molecule right so there are
various different ways that you might
want to modify your molecule you can add
and most uh it's not the most
interesting of modifications because it
just adds an atom it doesn't add a bond
if you want to add an atom and had it
have it bonded to something you had bond
oddly enough so we take a molecule we
add a bond between atom 6 and an oxygen
which is new and so that's how you can
add in a new atom that is bondage I
skipped ahead there I don't think going
over a delete atom delete bond probably
not that important this is interesting
though so modify a molecule transform
the atom coordinates alright so where
did I will just leave it like that so so
M is this we transfer so we make a copy
of M and we transform it to atom
coordinates using a translation
transform and then we can plot the the
two of them together and we see that
they that that indeed has happened so
the transformation function here can be
can be handy
think it can be a scaling transform and
you can end up looking molecule see I
want to get to here to replace
substructure because I think this one's
really neat so let's say you've got this
molecule right
right but you want to take look inside
that molecule and find a carbonyl or not
just a carbonyl but an ester right and
you want to replace this C double bond o
o with C f/c
so it's molecule modify and replace
substructure old goes to new and so as
you see the the oxygen was replaced by a
fluorine and the neighbor in the
neighboring oxygen also is now a carbon
you could take a molecule and replace a
benzene group with a cyclohexane yeah
that's good we've got to replace the
lists also there's plenty of nice
examples in there but I think that in
the interest of time we should just move
on to the fun stuff so you could take a
molecule modified start with norborne
Ain and end up with camphor this so we
define the two molecules here now we can
go from one to the other
just by adding four bonds in reality
we're adding four bonds plus atoms but
the add bond is the way is the easiest
way to do that we had a methyl group
here methyl here methyl here and a
double bonded oxygen there so we with
norborne Ain we add the bonds and is
this equivalent to camphor yes it is so
that's it's not quite a reaction I think
the chemical reactions are going to be
really interesting but they're gonna
have to wait for next so this is more of
a manual modification so this one I
thought was fun again we're gonna be
making some molecules here that probably
nobody would ever
want to but just for the fun of it
because we are it's it's a Gedanken
experiments right there with
cyclopentane we take that and we replace
every hydrogen every occurrence of
hydrogen on the molecule with benzene
and you ask yourself surely it won't be
you won't be able to embed that you
won't be able to come up with
coordinates for that well this is what
we got
and you might say man those guys are a
little crowded every one of those carbon
has two benzene rings attached to it
okay well let's replace the interior
cyclopentane structure with a cyclo
decade that is replacing the inner five
membered ring with a ten membered ring
and this one's tricky because you let's
see in our previous use of replaced
substructure we were replacing a the
substructure and the replacement had the
same number of atoms here we're
replacing a five membered ring with a
ten membered ring and in order to for it
not to do for it to do this
intelligently we have to tell it the
attachment points the the correspondence
between atoms in the pattern and atoms
in the replacement so we won one goes to
one we start at the beginning and then
for every index of the the pattern we
increment the the replacement index by 2
so 5 2 goes to 3 3 to 5 like this
okay well I'm gonna have to fix that
example but so it was it was working
just a little bit ago so what we have so
this so we took this interior five
membered ring and we replaced it with a
ten membered ring right so embedding
molecules in 3d this is a big deal
generating coordinates on the fly for
molecules is is not an easy thing to do
oh so a molecule when you're creating
one you can add the coordinates directly
to the expression or you can use the
coordinates that are generated
automatically if you provide them
they're gonna be different than than
what you would get then the automatic
coordinates and so so if you provide the
coordinates with the expression we will
use those if you want to not make those
coordinates at automatic if you want to
generate coordinates for them and place
them in the expression you can use
molecule modify with the compute atom
coordinates and so what this does is it
uses the method described in this paper
to to embed the molecule it compute a
distance bound matrix based on the
chemical graph so what this does so say
- so you want a matrix this n atoms by n
atoms and the element so between let's
say there are two carbons that are four
bonds away from each other when we know
that the the bounds four carbons that
are four bonds away from each other you
know they're going to be between three
angstroms and seven angstroms depending
on how floppy those four bonds are so
that so that's gonna have a loose bounds
whereas carbons that have just one bond
between each other you know they're
going to be want to be between 1.3 and
1.6 angstroms and so that's you fill out
you create the distance bound matrix
then you find a random distance matrix
that satisfies those bounds and then
from that distance matrix you generate
3d coordinates to match the
since matrix check that it's not insane
that it has reasonable energy and if it
does then you correct the structure
using torsion angles that were trained
on on actual experimental data from the
kanger Cambridge structural database so
so all that is happening when I say M is
this and molecule modify and compute the
atom coordinates and so now we have them
stored as a quantity array with a unit
of angstroms and you could convince
yourselves that they're identical to
what you would get if you use the
automatic coordinates so by you can also
use computer data compute atom
coordinates to generate random
conformers so we can do molecule modify
computer atom coordinates random seating
goes to automatic and so therefore it'll
be truly a random seed do that a hundred
times and about one and a half seconds
and you can look at the distribution of
energies for the conformers so these are
the the MMFF
energies but if you wanted to then you
could use that force field to minimize
the structures and you get a much much
tighter spread you could even use select
to generate to pick only those molecules
that have energy below a certain
threshold
you could also say you had a molecule
that had no stereochemistry and elements
but it had a structure 3d coordinates
you could use those 3d coordinates to
generate the the stereochemistry and so
here in this example I start with a
molecule that has stereochemistry
compute its coordinates then I remove
the stereochemistry which all that is
doing is taking away that option
stereochemistry elements goes to blank
so therefore now in the in the diagram
we don't see any stereochemistry no bond
no end wedges or dashes then but it does
have coordinates right so this guy has
coordinates but no stereochemistry so
now we look at those coordinates and we
regenerate the the stereochemistry just
from the coordinates and we see that the
end what you get is equivalent
right energy minimize atom coordinates
this used the Merc molecular force field
to to to find a local minimum geometry
so say you take a mall equals molecule
of water and look at its bond angle this
uses the automatically generated
coordinates these are fast coordinates
we get them really quickly comes back
with a bond angle of 106 degrees but if
we take that same structure and we
minimize the energy according to this
force field we get back something that
has a hundred and 3.9 degree bond angle
so the experimental gas phase bond angle
I think is a hundred and four point five
but basically you get the the bond angle
that is corresponding to your force
field so this force field the MMFF is
going to minimize this to about 104 what
I think is interesting is if you take
those waters that that from which we did
not so here ya generate a thousand water
molecules with using an automatic random
seed and look at the histogram of the
bond angles they're kind of all over the
place but if you want then you take
those same structures into a energy
minimization and we see the histogram
the values are a lot lot tighter right
base yeah those are very very tight so
you can also let's say it's almost time
to go so we're gonna you can set the
bond lengths at a bond angle right even
to ridiculous extremes should you so
choose right now we move on this is a
this is a pretty neat example this is in
basically every general chemistry
textbook they tell you ethane has this
particular torsional potential what this
is let's see do I right so here let's
say a molecule ethane
and we can so this is the the potential
right so you can take that molecule and
you can spin this torsional angle
basically and what it says is when these
two carbons are are overlapping with
each other then the energy is highest
when they're staggered the energy is
lowest and that's where you get this
kind of potential and so you can as you
see with these plots you can get the
same type of potential using the the
molecule functionality either by just
using set torsion angle directly you're
not modifying any other bond angles bond
lengths or by using the energy minimized
atom coordinates and setting us
constraints a set of constraints on your
the minimization forcing the the torsion
angle in question to be to have a
particular value but then letting
everything else relax to it and you get
the yellow curve versus the blue curve
so that's that's a neat example I think
right
we definitely have time for this okay so
chemical data sets are oftentimes really
D files this particular one is three and
a half gigabytes Shaun was just talking
about how those can just eat up insane
amounts of memory by reading them into
two Mathematica before parsing and so so
SDF parsing has gotten a lot better with
this so I'm not going to do it right now
but if I wanted to in just under a
minute I can take this this this file
and grab every let's see between
molecules 10 and 1 million in steps of a
hundreds so that brings in about 10,000
molecules out of a three and a half
gigabyte file you can look at random
molecules from there you can then with
that list of molecules defined and that
list of 10,000 molecules defined define
yourself a pattern for a carboxylic acid
you can then take and
for that for that pattern using molecule
contains cue select only the the
molecules in the list that contain the
carboxylic acid pattern and you'll find
a little over 1100 molecules have that
pattern you can then highlight those
patterns yeah right so what what do we
not cover we don't cover chemical
reactions that's something I think is
gonna be really interesting like so so
we need a symbolic representation for
them part of the whole point of this was
the molecule it's not just an entity or
a smile string we need a Wolfram
language symbolic representation for it
and that the next step we need a
symbolic representation for a chemical
reaction
they could be patterned based and then
they would apply to a broad range of
molecules so they could be specific with
specific instantiations of the pattern
they could store meta information the
kinetics spectator compounds my own
background is in quantum chemistry
electronic orbitals like this so that's
a direction I'm very interested in
moving next so a few things that I think
would be really interesting a
stereoisomer
enumeration tautomer standardization
tautomer enumeration these are coming
very those so those are hopefully coming
in the next release so right and then
I'd like to acknowledge the fact that
these open source tool kits are
underlying a lot of the functionality
here the Hobson parser is is really
amazing we started using it in alpha a
long time ago and it can just blazingly
fast some some really interesting
chemical names and so I don't have
enough well yeah time is kind of
stretched for me I've been focused on
this this for a long time look I just
want to point out these slides that you
can explore yourselves because everybody
has a copy of the
betta these experimental functions for
generating a resonance structures
looking at symmetry information you can
grab the the point group and plot I can
do that one real quick does anybody have
any questions so that there we go we
just created then we can find all of its
planes of symmetry all right does
anybody have any questions okay we'll
talk more about the symmetry fingerprint
similarity is also something that's
really cool you can create a molecule
here another molecule here and you can
get their fingerprints the fingerprints
of different varieties atom pairs
topological portions they come back as
bit vectors alright just a bunch of ones
and zeros and then you can find find
their similarities you could you could
search for use that as a distance
function in a and a nearest application
finding all the searching within a data
set for for the nearest match chemicals
and whatnot alright so but really though
I new questions no ok
um let's see I mean by job security
right it should never be done right
there should always be more there's
always more to more to do with it oh
yeah I know so we should be able to wrap
this up within a version or two I think
[Applause]